one of the real reasons we don't do the
things that frighten us is because we
are afraid of being judged we are afraid
of failure people might view me as a
risk taker I don't think myself that way
at all we get lost in our current
environment in our current world and
that prevents us from making smart
decisions
what's that believe nation it's
everything my one word is believe what I
believe my new I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world now I
started to believe life series to once a
week tackle a different problem a
different topic in personal development
to have this constant source of fuel for
you to continue to learn grow and get
better so let's live our best believe
life and today learn how to be a
risk-taker
enjoy
[Music]
first up let's talk about why it's
important to be a risk-taker with Mark
Zuckerberg in a world that's changing so
quickly the biggest risk you can take is
not taking any risk and I really think
that that's true right a lot of people I
think think that you know whenever it
comes to whatever you get yourself into
a position where you have to make some
some big shift and direction or do
something you know there are always
people are going to point to the
downside risks of that decision and
locally there may be right right I mean
if for any given decision that you're
gonna make there's upside and downside
but in aggregate if you are stagnant and
you don't make those changes then then I
think you're guaranteed to fail right
and not not catch up so to some degree I
think it's really right that over time
the biggest risk that you can take is to
not take any risks
now let's get to the how tip number one
is release your attachment to the
outcome with Robin Sharma release your
attachment to outcomes
now you say Robin whatever what are you
talking about
one of the real reasons we don't do the
things that frighten us is because we
are afraid of being judged we are afraid
of failure we are afraid of success we
are afraid of stumbling what I'm
suggesting to you is one of the reasons
we don't really step into our heroic
nature as human beings is because we're
attached to the outcome and so just
developing the philosophy where you live
in the moment you do the things that
frighten you and you don't really worry
about what happens that will develop a
sense of fearlessness and sense of
bravery tip number two define risk
clearly with Tim Ferriss
how to define risk you know this is an
important question because I realized
that a lot of the knots we tie ourselves
into and the a lot of the anxiety that
we feel is actually due to using words
that are not defined very well like
success I just want to be successful
well you better have a very clear
definition on what that is if it's gonna
be one of your mind and your main
obsessions young lady or young man yeah
happiness yeah that's a slippery one too
and risk is another one risk to me is
the likelihood of an irreversible
negative outcome yes that's it that's it
so define that way they're actually very
few serious risks and I choose to take
very few serious risks people might view
me as a risk taker I don't think myself
that way at all
tip number three is keep things in
perspective with me it's so easy to get
lost in your current situation it's so
easy to get lost in the present moment
and to be stuck and only look at the
trees instead of be able to take a step
up and see the forest and
a much bigger picture we get lost in our
current environment in our current world
and that prevents us from making smart
decisions that current world will change
so many times you will have many
opportunities to reinvent yourself over
the course of your life my own story
when I was in university I thought I
would wanted to be a banker I thought I
wanted to get a job I was working
towards getting a job I want to be a
bank cuz it's what I want to do
everything was geared towards that life
change right sudden shift meet these
entrepreneurs join this company and now
it's all about the software company and
building it up in biotech and I know
nothing about science I know nothing
about software and I'm young and I doubt
myself and if all these limiting beliefs
that was my world I sold it and then
what now I don't know what I want to do
I never become an adventure capitalist
and I'm all-in on being a venture
capitalist and learning and
understanding how to raise capital I'm
not super interested in it once I've
learned enough so I want to help
entrepreneurs how am I going to do that
I don't know I start by speaking I go to
the website now I'm all in on YouTube
YouTube won't be here forever right like
YouTube might last three years five
years ten years and then something else
comes along and that would be the next
shift and so I think it's easy to get
lost in the moment of what our current
short-term view of the world is and our
life is but when you have the exit
perspective to think of you know what
like I'm gonna have multiple careers
over my life like what happens right now
is not as important as you think it is
right it's not like you make one
decision here today and that's your life
for the rest of your life make the
decision if it doesn't work out it's
okay
you will adjust you will change once
YouTube dies down like this is my moment
right now I have to go all in on that
before that window closes
but once YouTube shifts it's okay I will
shift I will find the next thing I will
adjust right how the moment of
uncertainty and then find my next thing
and go hard on that and so the lesson
from this for me is when you find that
thing you got to do it because if your
goal is to be a youtuber as an example
if YouTube's not as big in five years or
ten years and something else is all the
rage like you missed your chance you
won't be a youtuber forever things will
change so when you have that idea when
you have that spark when you want to try
to do something instead of sitting on
the sidelines and watching somebody else
get rich off your idea
kicking yourself the saying I should
have done that like I had it all lined
up
right I had the idea I had the talent I
had the ability I just didn't believe in
myself I didn't take enough action
instead of just sitting on the sidelines
being that person do something and if it
doesn't work out it's okay
because you'll have multiple
opportunities in the future to continue
to reinvent yourself this one idea is
not your forever idea so just give it a
shot and see if it works out instead of
living the rest of your life wondering
what if tip number four is be more
personal with Brendon Burchard part of
taking a risk is being more personal
teaching yourself to share more to be
more vulnerable it's hard I get it you
know I'm in front of the camera in front
of stage all of my life I shouldn't say
my adult life I mean over the last 10
years of my life it's been a very public
journey for me you see if you're on with
us on Facebook you know this is we have
five million fans on this Facebook page
alone doesn't count our other facebook
pages you know we've just started and
we're going our Instagram channel hey
guys on Instagram I mean this has been a
journey for me of being in front of
public eye but even me for my next level
I'm gonna have to share more about my
personal life be more thoughtful about
that and that takes a lot of
vulnerability it doesn't scare me I just
know I need to do it and I'll give you
an example you know when I first started
my career in personal and professional
development you know because if you ask
me Brendon what do you do I would say
well I'm a writer first and I'm a
trainer second I've been blessed to
train more people on the topic
motivation to high performance than
anybody else in the world now our videos
have been viewed over a hundred million
times over 10 million fans across our
Facebook pages I've been blessed to
reach a lot of people but I can share
with you when I began my career I
thought I had to be mr. buttoned up you
know so proper and because I came from
the consulting world you know if you
ever had a real job in organizational
America and then you start doing this
it's hard not to be stiff you know and
not share as much but I I remember the
first time I ever shared with my
audience back then I shared with them
about how when I started my career I
went broke and I mean bankrupt broke and
I was in bankruptcy and I was
struggling to start my career do my own
seminars I had no idea what I was doing
you know
people were making fun of me I'm sure
people are making fun of me right now
and this life gasps and get used to that
part but you know it was new and it was
scary and I'll never forget though that
after I shared that so many people come
up to me and like I've struggled with
that - I've been bankrupt or I came from
poverty and I worked hard and I made it
- and and people would share their
stories with me and it was really
inspiring and taught me that you know
people won't believe your successes if
they don't believe the struggle you got
a share where you struggled more in life
and that feels like a risk but you know
you got to be honest does your family
and your friends and the people you
serve do they know what you really think
what you really feel what you really
desire in life what you're really going
after what you need because if they
don't know that about you that's not
taking risks look being quiet and
avoiding difficult conversation is not
taking risks and it's not the path to
growth the path to growth for so many of
us is another level of personal
authenticity another level of personal
sharing and if you don't do that then
you're not risking you're just going
through the motions and tip number five
the last one before the bonus flips is
assess risk properly with Tony Robbins I
interviewed these 50 unbelievable
investors had in common they're all
different
you know I interviewed people that are
macro traders and if you'd people like
Warren Buffett write value people
interview people that have blood in the
streets type of people you buy when the
world is going to hell and they're all
different but they had four things in
common real fast number one every single
one of them was obsessed with not losing
money guys like you and I tend to say
how do we make money for our companies
for ourselves as an investor their
entire focus is not losing money because
they know if you lose 50% it takes a
hundred percent get even well that's
about becoming comfortable with rest
well it's more than that these guys are
obsessed with not being comfortable the
risk they don't want to take right back
the second key that they do is they all
are focused on asymmetrical risk reward
most people think the most successful
investors take huge risks to get huge
rewards and in reality they take the
least risk humanly
possible to get the largest upside so
their whole focus is how do I get a
three to one or a five to one if I risk
$1 try to make five and I'm wrong like
risk and I can be wrong four times and
break even so they have a completely
different approach they're all very
focused thirdly on tax efficiency
because you only have the one you get to
keep and fourthly it's all
diversification and those four things
fundamentally are the frame from which
you start to design a portfolio
now that's a special bonus clips for you
but before getting to that my question
of the day today is what is the biggest
risk right now that you are afraid to
make in your business or your life what
is that big risk you're afraid to do
leave in the comments below I want to
hear from you thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus closed
hang with the heroes well if you
followed me before in other mastery
sessions or maybe it's Facebook or
Instagram or you've read my books you
know that I believe you become your
conversations because listening to an
audiobook or reading a book is nothing
more than having a conversation with the
author and you do become the people you
surround yourself with
and so what I'm encouraging you to
become fearless is to read the books of
people who have transcended adversity I
mean it might be a Nelson Mandela it
might be an Elon Musk
it might be a Martin Luther King jr. it
might be someone in your neighborhood
who overcame adversity and you decide to
have a conversation over coffee with
them I mean a lot of times the media
will ask me well Robin your books work
for people who had great backgrounds
people who have a lot of money people
who had the lucky breaks that's just not
true if you look at the people who
become iconic in business and in in
whatever the field might be most of the
time those are people who actually came
from nothing or they had a lot of
adversity but the adversity allowed them
to get to know their talents the
adversity developed their strengths the
adversity allowed them to become better
thinkers and they actually used failure
to develop greater levels of freedom and
one of the best ways to do that is to
read the books or listen to the audio
books or to spend time with people
who've overcome adversity who have been
frightened and they've over can send it
to higher levels of confidence and
bravery you engage in an unnecessary
risk when you act precipitously without
sufficient information or without taking
time to think it through carefully in
advance many of the mistakes that you
have made and and me for that matter
have occurred because you acted without
thinking that is you acted without
taking the time to minimize the risks
involved it's been said that you should
invest as much time and exact examining
or exploring and investment as you spent
earning the money to make the investment
you should do your due diligence you
should talk to experts in the field you
should get as much information as
possible
if you
for you make an irrevocable decision are
you a risk taker successful people are
but not just random a password like I'm
driving drunk without my seatbelt type
of risk I'm talking about calculated
risks you weigh the options you weigh
the potential outcome both good and bad
and you make the best decision possible
but guys I'm here to tell you that you
are never altum Utley going to be
successful unless you're willing to put
yourself out there having the ability or
the willingness the potentially fail is
an absolute benefit and sometimes these
calculated risks even though you thought
about them sometimes they just don't
work out and you know what successful
people do that's alright I learned
something I know what not to do next
time and you make another calculated
risk guys nothing great was ever
achieved because it was easy if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple
so it would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]